well thank you for that introduction mr.
bell as he mentioned I am a politics
major and I'm a political junkie and so
the topic of the CC is particularly
exciting for me I'm very interested to
hear the speakers we have for this week
I am honored to have the opportunity to
introduce our first speaker mr. Michael
Goodwin mr. Goodwin is the chief
political columnist for the New York
Post he began his newspaper career at
the New York Times serving as City Hall
bureau chief investigative reporter and
sports media columnist and later spent
three years as an adjunct professor at
Columbia University's Graduate School of
Journalism before joining the post in
2009 he was the political columnist for
the New York Daily News where he also
served as executive editor and editorial
page editor in 1999 he led the Daily
News editorial bird board to its first
Pulitzer Prize in 58 years for a series
of editorials revealing corruption at
the famed Apollo Theater a regular guest
on Fox News and Fox Business News and on
numerous radio stations he is the
co-author of I coke a 1985 unauthorized
biography of New York's former mayor
Edward I coke please join me in
welcoming mr. Michael Goodwin Thank You
Madeline
[Music]
and thank you to president Arne for your
remarkable and principled leadership in
the battle of ideas I am blessed and
deeply honored to be among all of you
here today this is my first visit the
beautiful campus of Hillsdale and I must
say I was truly impressed by the statues
alone nobody seemed to be writing
graffiti on them are trying to tear them
down George Washington Thomas Jefferson
graduate Douglas doesn't anybody know
they're here but more important than any
building or statue is hills dales
commitment to traditional American moral
and religious values that commitment
helped to guide me as I prepared my
remarks I hope you will find them
relevant to the task we are all engaged
in which is repairing our fractured
nation the question before us is not a
simple one is real corruption still
scandalous I'll repeat it is real
corruption still scandalous it presumes
that corruption still exists and nobody
can argue with the mountain of evidence
that it does but the devil lies in the
following words is that corruption still
scandalous the suggestion is that it
used to be but maybe isn't anymore my
answer begins with a paraphrase of a
lecherous former president it depends on
the definition of scandalous the common
definitions are shocking disgraceful
shameful abhorrent my favorite is
morally wrong all these choices point in
the same direction that a reasonable
person who knows corruption when he or
she sees it is outraged it implies a
common reaction that Springs from a
widely shared system of values but
that's where we run into trouble these
days
because of the rise of identity politics
and the polarization gripping Washington
there is no longer a common
understanding of who is the reasonable
American is it a white person a black
person an Asian a Latino a male a female
a transgender is a person of faith if so
which faith married or not
how old and from what state rural
suburban urban what about income what
about education
how about political differences is the
reasonable person in our test a
Republican a Democrat a liberal a
conservative a libertarian
regrettably nowadays we must also
include the option of socialist there's
a feature of our era that compels us to
ask these questions every kind of
difference has become a faultline
tearing at our shared values that is the
divided state of America today but
that's not the whole story I want to
share with you examples of where real
corruption is still scandalous and where
it is not and why that is so finally I
will offer some modest proposals about
what we can do to help fix our beloved
country I will start with the good news
there are numerous examples where there
is a broad sense of shared outrage over
corruption here's an important one from
New York State where I live early in
2015
Sheldon Silver the Speaker of the New
York State Assembly was indicted on
federal charges of illegally enriching
himself to the tune of 4 million dollars
through abusing his office
silver held the powerful speaker
position for twenty years and was safe
from challenge because Democrats held
about 100 of the 150 assembly seats
Republicans meanwhile control the other
legislative chamber the state Senate
a three months three mere months after
silver was indicted the Republican
Senate leader Dean Skelos was also
indicted on federal charges the charges
against Skelos were unrelated to those
against silver but equally infuriating
the allegations were that he had
pressured companies and donors to give
his son lucrative jobs some of which
were no-show jobs
young Adam Skelos it seems couldn't hold
a real job so daddy used his government
clout to get him a paycheck and health
insurance if not actual work as you can
imagine there was a great uproar about
the stench coming from Albany as I wrote
at the time it was a bipartisan stench
and since it involved the leaders of
both parties and both houses it
represented a moment of historic
venality Albany is different in all the
worst ways I wrote corruption there is
not a side gig it is the heart of the
matter it's a cesspool of self dealing
where almost nothing is done on the
merits among New York's many taxes and
I'm sure you've all heard of New York's
many taxes there's one that doesn't have
a real name but we call it the
corruption tax it's the one in beti than
the cost of living and doing business
there because the toll takers are on the
take it was a special moment when both
of these two leaders were indicted and
credit is due to Preet Bharara then the
federal prosecutor in Manhattan he took
down the two major players within months
and wasn't shy about the fact that he
was investigating the third key player
in the State Capitol
Governor Andrew Cuomo you've probably
heard of him too Cuomo a Democrat like
Sheldon Silver had once called himself
silver and Skelos the three amigos
because they met in a back room carved
up the budget and decided the fate of
all legislation you see in Albany there
are no serious hearings or floor debates
there are simply agreements among the
governor and the top two legislative
leaders then the bills are written to
confirm the agreements the late writer
Sidney Zion once said that Albany proves
there is something worse than
partisanship it's the kind of
bipartisanship where it's two parties
against the people this Albany habit
dates back decades and is widely
ridiculed as three men in a room and by
the way it's always been three men but
it never changes and here was Cuomo so
comfortable with the practice that he
felt secure enough to lure the
arrangement of the three amigos over the
public as though it were a joke but let
me say this about Andrew Cuomo there is
no such thing as a joke with him this
was his way of letting the public know
who was boss and thumbing his nose at
the calls for change I tell you these
details because corruption in the State
Capitol was so inbred that it looked
unfixable in recent years nearly forty
officials have been convicted of crimes
and that does not include Eliot Spitzer
the former governor was spared
prosecution I'm sure you remember him as
well in a prostitution case after he
resigned Spitzer was widely ridiculed as
quote client number nine and quote in
the charges against the ringleaders that
was our governor things were so bad that
in many years more legislators were
indicted than were defeated on election
day if you were not indicted you were
guaranteed re-election even if you were
indicted you usually still won
reelection but with the cases piling up
the mood changed corruption was no
longer a laughing matter the public had
had enough for example after their
arrest both silver and Skelos wanted to
keep their leadership positions saying
they would be vindicated at trial under
state law only felony convictions result
in expulsion from the legislature so
only their fellow legislators could
punish them and very few wanted to do
that the undemocratic ways of Albany
meant the leaders had total control over
every perk piece of legislation and
whether members kept party backing at
the next election it was a mafia-like
system that served to keep members in
line or else
so when silver and Skelos were indicted
the vast majority of members in both
houses Democrats and Republicans
remember were willing to let them stay
meaning they were willing to be led by
indicted leaders those Paul's oh they
are the embodiment of a new york saying
about the reformers who run for office
promising to clean up government it is
said quote they went to do good and
stayed to do well too many times public
service morphed into personal gain but
as I noted the mood had changed much to
the surprise of silver Skelos and there
at lackeys the public abandoned them
after a week in which outrage built and
calls for their removal grew both silver
and Skelos gave up their leadership
positions both were later convicted of
all counts against them and were
immediately expelled from their seats
the convictions were later set aside for
fairly minor reasons and both were
retried and convicted again on all
counts silver has been sentenced to
seven years in federal prison and Skelos
and his son are awaiting sentencing so
our answer in this case is yes real
corruption is still scandalous to the
public at large the United Front was
inspiring and there were scant descents
from the belief that Albany was rotten
to the core and something needed to
change that belief was shared by nearly
all the state's newspapers some of which
are conservative and many of which are
liberal even the New York Times which
often acts as if murderers are just bed
wetters did commendable work in
investigating both silver and Skelos the
gray lady made no calls for leniency now
there are clear several factors
contributed to this unified response
first a raft of corruption
had created wide disgust when the
leaders were arrested it amounted to an
aha moment
second the consensus was certainly
bolstered by the fact that the rot was
bipartisan there might have been a
different reaction if only the top
Democrat or only the top Republican had
been charged but with one from column a
and one from column B in the dock at the
same time there was no partisan split
everybody wanted to throw all the bums
out I'm sure each of you can point to
similar examples in your own communities
and I say that because in most cities
and towns still there is thankfully a
common center of traditional values and
shared experiences maybe not Chicago
thus what I'm about to say would
constitute bad news but it won't be news
at all that unity of shared values does
not extend to the nation's capital in
Washington real corruption is scandalous
only when it involves someone on the
other team when it involves someone on
my team it's no big deal
earlier I gave you a list of questions
about a reasonable person race and
gender and ethnicity and religion and
income there's one that trumps them all
politics in Washington fierce partisan
loyalty is crushing shared values if
there's a partisan angle to any issue
that can be exploited
then it's Katie bar the door more
troubling what happens in Washington
doesn't stay in Washington the divine is
trickling down in infecting politics at
all levels you hear it everywhere
friends and neighbors small towns even
families are being torn apart by
political differences no home workplace
or house of worship is immune so there
must be a sense of urgency about how we
respond the alternative is to watch
passively as the United States drifts
toward some form of national crack-up
already we see disturbing signs of
growing political
obviously the causes of this extreme
partisanship are numerous and they
clearly include media and technology
bill o'reilly the former fox news host
once said that cable news often teaches
people to hate each other
we also have to include social media and
it's obsessive fixation on this moment
events and even comments can in the
blink of an eye take on monstrous
importance far beyond anything rational
because hysteria is contagious people
everywhere are becoming outraged all the
time at what they regard as breaches of
acceptable behavior that wouldn't be so
bad if the vast majority were offended
by the same things then we could get big
things done instead the country is split
almost exactly in half over what people
are outraged about recall this example
when the IRS under then President Obama
singled out conservative groups to stall
their applications for tax free status a
fact admitted to by IRS official Lois
Lerner before she pleaded the fifth
amendment coverage was minimal in the
liberal media the associate oppressed
the Washington Post CNN etc didn't think
it was much of a story because they
weren't outright outraged by the
weaponization of the IRS to them it
wasn't corrupt and therefore it wasn't
scandalous or newsworthy of course it
wasn't they're ox being gored most
liberal journalists probably believed it
was a good idea to crack down on
conservative groups just prior to the
2012 presidential election by the way
Democrats rushed to support the IRS
after Obama himself insisted there was
not a smidgen of corruption in short
only half the country so saw the IRS
corruption as scandalous the other half
defended it the case stands out as a
watershed moment but in fairness it was
not the first four years the
polarization has becoming more
toxic it didn't start with Barack Obama
but it crossed a dangerous fault line
during his tenure as he reminded us just
last Friday if something offended half
the country the other half rushed to
embrace it it is so bad now that when we
ask whether real corruption is still
scandalous we can say yes but to only
half the country at any one time each
side has its own definition of what
constitutes corruption and its own
outrage machines to spread the word when
it comes to public corruption we have
two separate countries each attacking
and offending different things and that
was before a fellow named Donald Trump
burst on to the scene the severity of
the division now makes the IRS battle
look like the good old days every day it
seems one side or another declares that
Armageddon has arrived someday they will
be right to most of the 67 million
Americans who voted for Hillary Clinton
Trump's election is a form of public
corruption and so they find him
scandalous unwilling to accept his
victory as legitimate they insist it was
secured through collusion with Russia or
something even if they don't know what
or how they know whose entire presidency
is illegitimate and they are outraged
every day they call him unfit a traitor
a criminal the list is long and mostly
unspeakable now it's obviously true that
Trump is unlike any president in history
taking the Oval Office after a notorious
business career and personal life three
marriages even more bankruptcies and a
life lived on tabloid front pages and
reality television it's fair to say that
this is not the usual path to the
presidency and it's not as if he's
folded into the mold once he got elected
those policies are in general far more
conventional than his personality
hardly a day goes by when he does not
say or tweet something that breaks new
ground and not always for the better
each of these events is like fingers on
a chalkboard to those who hate him and
their hysteria what I and others call
Trump derangement syndrome gives them
license to say the most vile things
harass his aides and hound them off of
airplanes and out of restaurants
funerals I'm thinking of John McCain's
and Aretha Franklin's are no longer just
about the dead but what the living think
about Trump and try watching an NFL game
without getting into a discussion about
players kneeling during the national
anthem
today was opening day for most of the
teams I didn't watch I didn't want to
didn't want to know the stories Trump is
such a lightning rod that a Kentucky
Democrat running for Congress compared
his election to the terror attacks on
9/11 imagine that but so far until we
have evidence to the contrary we must
say that Trump won the election fairly
and can point to many successes in his
administration the economy is clearly
booming and there is a job for just
about everybody who wants one under his
america-first agenda he is correcting
imbalance in foreign relations by trying
to fix trade deals that disadvantaged
American workers and companies he's
pushing NATO members to pay their fair
share of the common defense the
qualifications of his judicial
selections of solid across the board and
if Brett Kavanaugh is confirmed to the
Supreme Court we could see the most
constitutionally conservative Court in
our lifetimes as I wrote recently the
Supreme Court has more than less been
tilting to the left since Dwight
Eisenhower made Earl Warren Chief
Justice in 1953 as a result of these
accomplishments most Trump supporters
see no scandal in anything he does only
in what others do to him
whether it's Special Counsel Robert
Muller's probe or the bias of the
liberal media they believe Trump is
under siege in an attempted coup
they voted for him knowing his
background because they wanted results
they were not getting from either party
and most are getting those results and
so they defend him no matter what he
does his line that he could shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue and still keep
his support is probably only a slight
exaggeration we could say such blind
support is also a form of Trump
derangement syndrome but make no mistake
it is the Trump deniers and the
resistance movement that are making this
era so troubled consider the conduct of
the mainstream media which has been
abandoned all standards of fairness and
continues to embarrass itself with overt
bias against the president I've been
writing and talking about this
phenomenon for over two years now
yet I'm stunned on a near-daily basis at
the SHA dienes of the so-called gems of
the National Press the New York Times
The Washington Post ABC CBS NBC they
give the impression their sole aim is to
destroy the President of the United
States this is a form of public
corruption but only half the country
finds it scandalous not to be sure the
other half millions upon millions of
Americans avidly consume this openly
bias media and while the media
businesses everywhere challenged by
technology and cultural forces it is a
fact a startling fact that being anti
Trump has been good business for many of
the purveyors this is the exact opposite
of shared values the half of the country
that is outraged by Donald Trump's
presidency and calls it corrupt is happy
to support media that have abandoned
their traditional standards of fairness
and principles thus we must abandon hope
that those media outlets will be
punished financially for their partisan
attacks there's no business incentive
for them to be fair even the minimum we
might expect that they would stop using
so many anonymous sources
and separate so-called straight news
from opinion does not appear likely to
happen bias is good for the bottom line
witness the sensation the New York Times
created with its Anonymous op-ed said to
be from a senior official in the
administration it was a PR bonanza and
drew millions of eyeballs to The Times
website
clickbait and it's a big moneymaker
another case where public corruption is
only skandhas for half the country
involves some federal agencies it's a
fact that the Justice Department the FBI
and others took liberties that were
morally wrong and probably illegal
because they didn't want Donald Trump to
be President some individuals like
former top agents and lovebirds Lisa
Paige and Peter struck were dumb enough
to put it in writing on government
computers although former director James
Comey deputy director Andrew McCabe
struck Paige and other leaders of the
FBI were fired or demoted based on
misconduct the current director
Christopher Rea acts as if the
unprecedented events of 2016 and 2017
are mere reputational dents count him
among those who don't find that
corruption scandalous he has support in
the liberal media of course which scoffs
at the idea that what the FBI did is a
scandal at all it was merely just a few
agents privately giving their views of
Trump nothing to see here
move along that in turn outrages the
Trump half of the country which sees
both the FBI and the media as corrupt
and untrustworthy again the same set of
facts are scandalous to some but not to
others as for Democrats reaction to
Trump let's just say the grief does not
seem limited to three five seven or even
ten stages it's endless
their answer to his presidency can be
roughly divided into two groups
political assassination and political
suicide
the assassination group is putting all
its chips on special counsel
their hope their dream their fantasy
their everything is that Muller will
find collusion obstruction or anything
that will lead to impeachment and
removal some even believe stormy Daniels
will lead them to the promised land
political suicide is a path other Dems
are taking as they embrace any shiny new
thing including socialist socialism the
leftward lurch got a jolt last June when
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez a 28 year old
former bartender defeated incumbent Joe
Crowley in a primary House seat in
Queens New York in a flash Ocasio Cortes
was the darling of the party and some
insiders declared she was its future
this is after winning a primary they
climbed on board when she called for
abolishing the immigrations and Customs
Enforcement police known as ice briefly
the idea felt unstoppable until cooler
heads realized that one abolishing the
agency would lead to border chaos and to
border chaos would lead to a Republican
route in the midterms
besides Ocasio Cortes revealed that she
was ignorant and confused about many
things
her claim that unemployment was low
quote because everyone has two jobs
end quote was a gift to comedians and
Republicans and this is a note to the
Hillsdale bragging rights to the
Hillsdale economics staff
Acacio Cortez has a degree from Boston
University with a major in economics
can't make this stuff up right
then there is the dismal performance of
the Democrats congressional leaders
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi they
began by thinking they could negotiate
with Trump on big-ticket items including
infrastructure and immigration Schumer
also thought that because he and Trump
knew each other they could work together
in fact Trump had been a big contributor
to Schumer over the years but both he
and Pelosi work out by the left-wing
mobs that threatened their jobs early on
one late one night demonstrators
appeared outside Schumer's apartment
house in Brooklyn screaming and chanting
until midnight they had nothing to say
except no no no cooperation shouting
screw Chuck though of course in truth
they used the word for screw that rhymes
with Chuck clever huh Chuck learned his
lesson and quickly joined the suicide
caucus the missed opportunities include
the tax bill Democrats could have helped
to rebalance the mix of cuts in personal
and corporate rates but that would have
meant some Dems would have to a vote yes
in exchange not a single one did and the
Democrats made no effort to actually fix
or reform the bill in any way that is
how Trump derangement syndrome affects
policies dear to every American and
another way in which polarization grows
so here we are half the country approves
of Donald Trump's presidency and the
other half is offended by his existence
under these circumstances we are doomed
to look in vain to Washington for
examples a public corruption that are
still scandalous to all Americans or
even to a consensus where do we go from
here I will make two points first I've
often mentioned the need to join the
side you are on
I repeat that that's a quotation join
the side you are on
I first heard the great writer midge
Dekker used that phrase years ago and it
stuck with me as
is an essential ingredient in any
solution it translates in the supporting
media outlets you find worthy especially
in premise as well as supporting civic
groups and political candidates your
country needs you so don't be a
spectator get involved join the side
you're on second and more fundamentally
we must realize that the founders gave
us a way out of this predicament
it's federalism or the separation of
powers between Washington and the states
now I'm hardly the first to say that the
federal government has gotten too big to
succeed in fact it is so big that it can
only fail in most of what it does think
about your own reaction when you read
about how such-and-such federal
government is rife with fraud waste and
abuse
you are certainly outraged but you're
not surprised unfortunately your
expectation of failure is rational the
core mistake that plays out time and
again is that Washington is the font of
all wisdom and can solve every problem
the trend is getting worse thanks to
technology which tends to nationalize
any controversial event the prevent
proliferation of cameras and videos
propels routine incidents onto the
national stage and a heartbeat a police
shooting a lost child a protest boycott
neighbor disputes the everyday grab bag
of local issues are often deemed to
require national solutions because
social media spread them far and wide
this is utter and total nonsense and
merely piles up problems on the
doorsteps of Congress that nobody
believes will be solved that pile just
becomes more grist for gridlock
meanwhile the role of the states in the
federal system works well when it is
allowed to the states have developed an
unique fashion depending on natural
resources and local populations
traditions and politics nowadays we look
at states in the political shorthand of
in blue we see certain characteristics
that are more common in blue states such
as higher taxes and more regulations and
we see other characteristics common in
red states such as lower taxes and fewer
regulations in reality
lots of people in businesses see
appealing aspects to both and to the
mixed approach that many other states
offer if there were not advantages to
more than one model all 320 million
Americans would flock to a handful of
states that they haven't is testament to
the wisdom of federalism that states
would be laboratories for new ideas and
programs that might or might not be good
national policy these laboratories are
how problems get addressed if taxes or
crime are too high or if public
education is failing citizens have more
power to fix it or they are free to move
to other states
either way the structure offers paths
for self correction while also
guaranteeing maximum Liberty for
individuals from a one-size-fits-all
national government there is then plenty
of evidence to conclude that federalism
is working much as the founders hoped
the problem is that we don't take
sufficient advantage of it and we've let
Washington bite off much more than it
can chew we need a back to local
movement and I believe there are lots of
green shoots of just such a movement
that is the goal of a group that Tom
Coburn the respected former senator from
Oklahoma is working with called citizens
for self-governance it wants a
convention to propose amendments to the
Constitution that would reduce
Washington's Authority and impose term
limits on Congress I don't is there
anyone here who doesn't think we need
term limits on Congress Nebraska senator
Ben Sasse at the Cavanaugh Supreme Court
hearing also gave an excellent
I thought excellent analysis of the
problem
arguing that Congress has punted too
much of its authority to the
unaccountable bureaucracy by passing
these giant omnibus bills containing
thousands of pages they are read only by
bureaucrats and lobbyists who then add
thousands of more pages of regulations
this leads to the giant blob noticed the
administrative state which in turn leads
to endless lawsuits and Court decisions
and gives judges up and down the line
ever more power SAS cited that
unintended and largely undemocratic
reality as a reason why the Supreme
Court has become such a political
battleground and why it is viewed as a
super legislature what we need is a
congress that functions as it when it
was intended he argues these are all
good points but even the optimist among
us would admit that bureaucrats and
members of Congress will not voluntarily
yield the power to spend other people's
money but as with the New York
corruption case that I cited it wasn't
the governor or the legislators that
took away the leadership spots of the
indicted leaders it was a bipartisan
public revolt that changed reality
that's what we need on a national level
and hard though it may be to pull off I
see no other alternative to his credit
President Trump despite sending mixed
signals on his view of federalism and
executive power has reduced many federal
regulations one of his most significant
initiatives is a new environmental
policy that proposes to let States
regulate coal burning power plants
instead of Washington it was fascinating
to see the instant reaction of
bureaucrats and environmental activists
the change they claimed would mean 1,400
premature deaths each year now how they
could draw such a precise conclusion
before the states even had a chance to
begin
considering what they would do tells you
the real agenda they want Washington to
control these things because
concentrated power is easier to
influence and better for them instead of
having to convince voters lawmakers and
governors in 50 states special interest
advocates can set up shop in Washington
Lobby a handful of congressional leaders
and agency heads and presto they get the
outcome they wanted imposed on the
entire nation during the Obama years
there was another scam that came to
light the EPA secretly worked up cozy
deals with radical activists the plot
had the activists sue the agency
demanding that it takes certain actions
instead of fighting the claims the
agency would settle the suit by giving
the advocates everything they wanted
that way new regulations sometimes
onerous ones could be imposed without
the trouble of getting legislation
passed or even going through the public
comment period normally required it was
simply a court approved settlement of
the claims we've had much too much of
that in America and it's choking our
economy and depriving generations of
opportunities it's also a fundamental
violation of the spirit and I believe
the letter of the Constitution one thing
we know for certain we cannot fix
Washington by adding layer after layer
of new bureaucrats to monitor the ones
we have the best choice is to send more
power back to the States
it can't happen all at once but we can
chip away at the blob
it's a lifetime's work and we may not
finish it but we can make a meaningful
difference by joining the side we're on
when we do that the polarization over
which we despair will shrink and
Washington can better focus on issues
that only it can address including
defense and in
vitamin programs that was the founders
vision it is time we return to it after
all we've tried everything else and look
at the mess we made back to local is the
best way forward thank you very much for
your attention
because you
[Applause]
mr. Goodwin we now have time for a few
questions please raise your hand and
wait for a microphone to be brought to
you great summary but you didn't mention
the tenth amendment would you care to
address how it may help or hinder will
tell me what you're thinking what's your
how you tell me how you think it would
help it's the perfect example of how we
surrendered but it's the only one of the
first ten amendments that is properly
named it should have been instead of the
Bill of Rights the bill of restrictions
on the federal government so if we take
those two things together and say let us
name and use the wording Congress shall
make no law more often and say founding
fathers were great except and then say
we the people have surrendered what the
10th amendment confirmed yeah look I I
think that's a that's a reasonable point
but I don't think that that is what's
creating this I I think that we are
simply now in a period where it's time
for a change of culture
this thing is so screwed up I don't
think it's going to be a legal mechanism
I think the Supreme Court is certainly
going to help but I think it's going to
have to be a public revolt that forces
Congress to do these things down the
road we may get there but I think in the
beginning it's it's it's got to start
just by individual members of Congress
saying no to these omnibus bills which I
really believe SAS is on to the key
hinge between all of these things it is
this giant legislation that just only
Washington can do it and there's no way
to get out of it that that I think is
the biggest problem of all mr. Goodwin
thank you very much for speaking I was
curious to hear what you thought of the
question you asked at the beginning
this talk so in the in this age of
increasing identity politics and
political intolerance who nowadays is a
reasonable American well yes that is
that's the rub isn't it what I was
attempting to do with the initial the
New York State example is that there are
cases and times when it doesn't matter I
mean New York is as diverse as any state
in America and it's got all of these
blue state issues it's got all of these
radical identity politics groups and yet
on this issue corruption they were able
to come together and as I said I think
that maybe the circumstances were unique
because it it had been going on the US
Attorney was essentially crusading
against it
you had had the bipartisanship so I
think that the fracture can be overcome
in certain circumstances but I think it
takes a set a set of events happening
together in that case and I think in
Washington we cannot overcome it we have
to get out of Washington so that's where
I think that the states are the pradhans
work in the States they are not working
in Washington at all right now yes could
you role play this out for let's say
conservatives that live in say
California or Colorado and it seems that
scandals and political oppression by
leftist seems to be part of the culture
would if you role played that out the
scenarios would it be do you vote with
your feet what's gonna happen in those
areas I'm sorry I didn't hear the last
what would happen in those states which
are effectively controlled under a
federalist ik model they would be
controlled by left left-wing powers yes
as they are anyway and and I think that
it would it would in effect create it
make it so obvious and they probably
there would be no brake on it
politically that you would probably have
a totally blue state before long I mean
you've got this this effort to a secede
from the United States since President
Trump was elected then you've got the
separate effort to break California into
three states so I think clearly there
there are conniptions going on in
California I think that if it did become
its own country that would be punishment
enough
Hey
my name is Jerry Casey my question
involves Illinois of which I am a former
resident and now I'm a resident of
Florida but the existence of everything
that you have talked about in terms of
New York has been true in Illinois for
since Anton Cermak was mayor and the
state legislature Michael Madigan has
been the Speaker of the House for I
believe 38 out of the last 40 years
right they have a super majority in both
houses how does one bring up the fact
that something has to be done like New
York we have the two-term limit for
governor now one term in office one in
jail and it it is very good one it is
very disheartening to an individual who
lives in that state to know that their
vote means nothing the first time my
vote meant anything nationally was in
Florida I I'd love to see what you're
talking about in New York happened in
Illinois but I don't know how it can
what would you suggest well look III the
fact that you no longer live there is is
one of the things that happens when
these things get so bad and I for the
life of me I mean I was both surprised
and but not shocked when Rahm Emanuel
decided not to seek re-election I don't
know how he won the last time given the
murder rates in Chicago I mean Fe you
know coming from New York and I was a
journalist all through the 70s in the
80s and 90s and I mean murder was the
fact of life every day in New York
during the the worst period when David
Dinkins was mayor averaged 2000 murders
a year it now has 300 and that fall-off
I believe was sold almost exclusively to
policing but properly led policing by a
Mayor Rudy Giuliani
and then later Michael Bloomberg who
decided this was intolerable the people
and that's why Giuliani was elected
because the public found it intolerable
why Chicago re-elected Rahm Emanuel with
those murder rates to me if that wasn't
a crisis what is a crisis and so until
the public wakes up some of these states
I think it's going to take maybe it's a
bankruptcy although states can't
technically go bankrupt but Illinois has
the worst of all problems but financial
with its pensions as well as murder you
would think that and people would either
leave or find new representatives to
guide the city but Chicago it stands out
as a case that has done neither and for
the life of me I can't figure it out
I've never lived there I've never really
worked there so I don't know what the
what the mood is but it usually takes a
crisis to make a change right you think
of one term presidents one term mayor's
one term governors it's always a crisis
it's not just things are bad it's a
sense of you're in a death spiral and I
would think that Chicago is in something
of a death spiral but apparently not to
enough people anyway but maybe
something's changing when okay as
Emanuel would run again if he thought he
could win I think he doesn't want to
lose and that would be the end of his
career so better to step off and still
have an opportunity for something else
that that would be my reading of his
reading of what's happened there so
maybe there's a little bit of Hope
coming over here so yeah
raise your hand again if you had a
question please Gary here we go Mike's
coming right behind you we have a
question to the speakers okay my name is
Robert Brown and I have a small business
in Toledo Ohio and before the EPA it was
a relatively simple business when the
EPA got in it became a lot more
difficult all the things you had to do
to compete and it absolutely is
ridiculous how can the EPA keep on being
such a stripper Asst type division of
the government that's number one and
number two the Department of Education
is certainly much better left to the
states and should be done away with in
the federal government yeah look I think
I think the EPA forget created by
Richard Nixon or under Richard Nixon
before because there were crises of
clean air and clean water the Cuyahoga
River I recall and in Cleveland caught
on fire and that sort of thing was
happening but I think that clearly it
has become now cease or at least it was
under the Obama administration seized by
what most of us would regard as radicals
that they wanted to expand the power so
that they controlled what happened to
every piece of land every everything
that could possibly harm the air or
water without regard to people's
livelihoods to the cost of all of this
stuff I'm even though they're mandated
to and to include the cost in any
analysis they they just get around it
and these legal settlements that I
mentioned I thought was amazingly
notorious what they were doing they
would cozy up to the radical activists
on the outside and basically say why
don't you sue us and we'll give you what
you want because we want it too but we
just can't get there the normal way so
that end run around
democracy is what big government loves
to do I'm the same with secrecy right
big government loves secrecy it thrives
on it because the less you know the
better it is for them so I think there
are a lot of these things that come
together education I'm of two minds I
think there is a role for the federal
government but I think it's clearly
overstepped that role a long time ago
but the EPA same thing there's a role
but they've clearly overstepped it so I
think getting these things right-sized
again I think SAS whom I'm not a fan of
in general Ben Sasse but I think he's
got a really good idea I think I think
he stated it very clearly at a right
time that this is why the Supreme Court
has become such a nasty political
battleground it's because Congress is
not doing its job yes I'm Bob Kay from
Austin Texas how do you view
gerrymandering as a sustainer of the
divide in our country I'm sorry so the
name again gerrymandering how do you
gerrymandering what's he running for you
know I I am confused about
gerrymandering because it of course goes
way way back but there is a certain
amount of it that's required by the
courts in order to give minority
representation now I forget the exact
number now but there is there is a
belief that for a non-white person to be
elected in a minority in a district it
has to be something on the order of 55
or 60 percent minority I forget what it
is now it's something I think it's
somewhat varied over the years and so
what you will see for example I am
familiar with New York there is a
congressman
congresswoman on the name Nydia
Velazquez whose district encompasses
part
of Manhattan the Bronx and queens in
order just to find every Hispanic
surname they could now this is clearly a
violation of compact and continuous
which is what districts are supposed to
be but it is done under under the courts
rubric to guarantee minority
representation so as a result there are
fewer Hispanic surnames in other
districts I mean it just has all these
ramifications that I think make no sense
so if we're going to allow
gerrymandering for race then we're
already created I think a lopsided a
lopsided playing field for everyone else
you either gerrymandering is okay or
it's absolutely verboten I think the
court needs to make up its mind on that
thank you
thank you all
[Applause]